if someone could give me it just feels like panning for gold right it's like if someone could give me
a directory listing of every web server at a company i would be able to show them so many
vulnerabilities and it's actually and that's actually not that hard for the companies to do
and no one's ever taken me up on it but i think it'd be really just
best part of hacking when you can just you know critical things
already critical thinking community the time the much awaited time has come where we announce who
the next co-host is who's going to be my uh my partner in crime on this podcast and as you may
have guessed it is none other than rezo himself so dude i'm so excited to have you on the team thank
you so much for taking the position and um i guess i just wanted to give you a little bit of a platform
right now to talk about um you know why you're such a great fit for this role um as the co-host and
also you know you're going full-time bug bounty in like what seven days or something so just talk about
you know that plan and that transition yeah when this podcast comes out it will have been yesterday
so i went full-time yesterday to the listeners no yeah i appreciate it i mean i think that uh it's it's
a good fit for me because i'm a massive fan of cdbb and i think that uh it's another good fit because
like you said i'm going full-time bug bounty i've been passionate about it for five or six years
trying to go but work kept reeling me back in and so now it's it's the right time for me and it's also
you know a potentially a great time for uh critical thinking um yeah to i guess the to the platforms uh
send me all your invites and uh life hacking invites to the events uh but no in general um if
listeners do want to reach out um super open to collaboration super open to to learning or to
mentoring you know like just reach out to me and and chat with me i'll be active in the critical
thinking discord so yeah i'm excited to have another full-time hunter you know as the co-host as well
because it's a different world i think when you're in it all day every day um and uh so i'm excited to
have you there um you know we we met at the live hacking events um can you tell the listenership a
little bit about your journey from uh you know where you started in bug bounty and how you ended up at the
live hacking events where we met and how we landed where we are today yeah yeah credibility is a huge
thing i want the listeners to know that i'm in the trenches with the have been dealing with the dupes
dealing with the nas and the informationals for a long time now so yeah uh when i initially got
started honestly i was listening to or i was seeing like tweets and stuff from doggy g and nahamsec
and people like that and i was like man this feels like it could be something that's like fun and
lucrative and career building and i honestly think that you know that would be my pitch to people who
are listening that aren't doing bug bounty yet it's like even if you make no money you're building an
awesome skill set you're having a ton of fun you're basically in my opinion getting like the privilege
of doing something that people in the past risked their skin for right like yeah people had to go to
jail like we're like scared they would go to jail because they would be hacking things but it was just
like such an intense passion in them and like a curiosity that they wanted to sate and now you can
actually um kind of quench that that desire and get paid to do it so i think that's really cool but
when i first got started um i was like i'm in security i was doing blue team stuff and i was like
i already know how to write code so i feel like i have like two kind of small advantages there and i
want to pivot that into into like being fat like acquiring bug bounty skill and uh profit like kind of
quicker so i uh you know i would like hack along with ben when he was doing those like live streams he
would do like the live recon streams and stuff and um so many amazing hackers came out of those live
streams really and ben is what a what an amazing service to the community he does with his uh with
his live streams and his hack alongs yeah yeah we should we should do some of those sometime but yeah
um but yeah kind of there quickly thereafter i found some good vulnerabilities i knew that i would
need an edge at the beginning when i was liking the skill so i would try to go after brand new targets
and so i did that through new public launches and then through like you know my first few private
invites which you know i valued so highly i would get it and just like drop everything and sprint to
it um my first live event was actually the yahoo uh open scope the kind of open to anyone which was
perfect for me because i had never been invited to one right so there was there was like 3 000 people
that hacked in it um i was fortunate enough to get an early invite to the bug bounty forum slack which you
know some listeners will definitely know about and um and had partnered up with douglas day hussein
uh uh jesse hogarth and then eric um with code code can care of course today is new and we ended up
winning best team in that event uh across every round and so it was highly beneficial dude dang yeah that
is that is quite a team i have to say i understand why that why that turned out the way that it did yeah and
what's crazy is i was a little worried about pulling my weight but in the first round my fuzzing and
automation found a sick crit that like resulted in like a plea stop bonus if anybody knows what that
is from yahoo back in the day and it was like it paid out like 18 000 i think but um it was really
cool because it was a web.zip in like another directory but it was it was hosted on their
infrastructure where it was only uh landing one in 12 times so once i found i was like how did no one
find this so then i kept buzzing it there was a round robin there was only one proxy that it would
actually like let you download the content from and so anyways that was just like a dream come true
and then of course once i think once we um got best team in that it guaranteed another invite and then
you know i was like i've been on a lot of uh douglas day our game the archangels uh you know
collaboration teams um through the years through the through the events and so that snowballed into
some other invites and so yeah i think i'm at like 11 000 reputation points but um my my last 90 days
looks pretty pitiful um i've been hacking on google and then trying to wrap up stuff at the job so i'm
excited to get the stats stats pumping again i i know i know you've been doing a great job with the
google stuff too i've been kind of poking at them the past couple days and i'm going to be going going
ham now for the next week um on them and the scope that they have is really interesting the the changes
they've made to their program are really attractive too so i definitely see them being one of my main
targets in in uh in 2025 if i can if i can just like i i gotta break through that that mentality
because i found a couple bugs on google before but like i like google is just such an intimidating
target right it's just it is but but and all that if you really think about it stuff like uh if you
really think about it though gcp is so similar to aws and people spend like their whole life hacking
aws and and succeeding you know so i this isn't in our docket but i did want to talk to you about this
specific thing now that you bring it up because i was thinking about this in the shower actually
i know you're a uh a good a good idea in the shower boy yourself but hot water what is it about hot
water that makes us have amazing ideas yeah i don't know i think it's just the only time our brain gets
to rest because we like shove stuff in front of our face all the all the rest of the time but uh what
was dawning on me was like there are definitely different applications which are more fun and less fun
to hack and actually the kind of obfuscated uh you know nature of proto buff actually does
make it a less enjoyable experience like i was just thinking on the spectrum of like what's fun
to hack what's not and i think that like if a company does have like more obfuscation or more
whatever less people hack on of course and that makes it a good target from a bug bounty perspective
but i was just thinking about how that's kind of interesting and i want to shift my mind in that
regard too it's like just because it doesn't feel that enjoyable immediately how could i make it
enjoyable whether i write a plug-in or whether i use ai automation to like kind of reverse the proto buff or
maybe i think about it in a different way or i look for a different type of bugs it's kind of interesting
yeah 100 i mean and and that that lack of fun you know when you're first looking at it that that
additional friction there makes your competition much less too so that's one of the reasons why i've
been excited to kind of work on google stuff is like i know that if i can crack the egg then it's going
to be really really profitable yeah especially with their increased bounties they've got recently so
um i think that's that's pretty solid um and actually i was a little bit surprised when you
when you said that that pathway um you know with with the team that you had on the yahoo event and
how your automation found stuff because i didn't really have you in my head as a as as much of an
automation guy like are you are you looking to kind of dip back into the automation realm as you go
full-time hunter are you going to focus more on manual stuff or you know where do you kind of put
yourself on the manual to recon hacker yeah fantastic question i would say um my my inroad was
definitely automation like i i followed um hadix's uh what's it called how to how to shot web or like uh
bug bounty hunters methodology yes the bug bounty hunters methodology i think it was version two when
i was getting big so version one was already down i basically built that exact pipeline on a random vps
on digital ocean and used that for a long time and i would say the vast majority like over 50 of my
bugs for the first probably three years came from big fuzzing and from that that type of automation
um you know when a new program spun up i would definitely go in and just immediately look for
i doors and all that regular stuff but my bread and butter that i would come back to every night like
everyone go to sleep in the house and i would hack for two hours it would be like always fuzzing
and uh you know initially it was like durbuster or something like that but very quickly it became ffuf
um i would i would i would venture to bet that i've sent more requests and ffuf than
point you know 99.9 of of all bug buddy hunters that's crazy i have famously been warned for uh
dosing and like three or four different live hacking events so sorry sorry about that i like to spin up
fleets of um axiom host and then kind of fuzz from there um yeah i don't know i think that if someone
could give me it just feels like panning for gold right it's like if someone could give me a directory
listing of every web server at a company i would be able to show them so many vulnerabilities and
it's actually and that's actually not that hard for the companies to do and no one's ever taken me
up on it but i think it'd be really interesting just to go to a really interesting concept yeah yeah
it's not necessarily as simple with that as that with modern architectures because it's not like
we're not we're not dealing with as much of like we talked about this on an episode like art of the
architecture is uh way back there but um you know we talked about how there's sort of more like this
flat file architecture where you've got like uh this is more something you see more in like a php sort
of environment where you've got you're exposing a file system to the web via web server right but then
now you know what's becoming more popular is like these single page applications backed by apis and stuff
like that um but i mean you're right even if companies would just give you give the the um
directory listings for you know these sort of flat file based um architectures that they have that
would be i mean you would just because all that stuff's out there anyway it's just security by
obscurity right um and a lot of times uh even in the new architectures they'll still like mount full
folders oh yeah so like so like it'll still be at a specific path yeah exactly um so anyways that was
the initial part of my journey i would say the last two years it's been a little bit more manual you
know a lot of ai hacking um but then a lot more manual testing i think that basically i i haven't
really used my server i like i got to spun back up in the last two months because obviously i'm about
to go full-time and i want to do a lot more recon in that regard but before before that i would say for
the last two years it's been a lot more manual hunting manual hacking um and then that's also during
the time when i transitioned from burp to kaido because you know i'm not using the necessarily
the scanner the active scanner as much so yeah yeah yeah wow okay that that all makes sense i mean
i've seen you at the live hacking events and stuff but i hadn't had you sort of categorized in either
one of those arenas but it seems like you kind of have a similar um approach as an ugly which is like
you know there there is some some automation stuff going on but like when you need to get down to it you
also get in there and you find the idors and you find the you know application level bugs
um beyond just the recon world um yep so that's really cool man um so you're you're going full-time
bug bounty uh yesterday so what's the what's the plan for for how you're gonna how you're gonna do that
i mean obviously we we've got the full-time hunters guild which um i'm uh i i know you're gonna be an
active participant in um but what's your plan moving forward on like what kind of targets you're gonna
hit how often you're gonna try to hack that sort of thing yeah i think that as far as the targets go it's
still a little bit up in the air i'm i definitely want to spend some time on google like you mentioned
um i plan to actually basically i've always felt like new scope like untouched scope is the way to
go so this is maybe giving away my secret a little early but my goal is going to be to pull the top um
like the you know basically pull all the top programs that i trust or the other hunters trust
and maybe maybe out of a list of like 30 or 40. um get the get the ones that are wild carded then from
those do some sort of recon that basically tells me hey here are the assets that have been spun up in
the last three months to kind of narrow it down to just those and then work my way through that list
so i know the program's good i know they pay well i know they pay street research as well i know they
have open scope and then i know that these domains or these features yeah i might also just look at
change logs for those companies as well i do that a lot for google yeah that that's yeah that's big i think
i think that that's some some uh stuff that i'm going to be setting up i've already got a couple of them
monitoring right now but i think i'm going to try to build that out this year every target that i
hack on religiously i'm going to onboard into my change log monitoring or js file monitoring to see
when changes occur to um the api endpoints on that specific app i i think it's kind of a waste not to
if you're already taking notes you already have your whole brain in this app you understand how it
works now you need to um one of the takeaways that i had from an episode with sam erb was taking notes
with code right that's what i'm going to do here is like take notes with code uh to to automate you
know my understanding of this app and make sure that i'm i'm developing that understanding over
time as that app continues to develop yeah exactly and i mean like not only can developers increase
bugs at that level because that there these are new changes and new features um but also i think that
as you learn the app you can see where there's going to be regressions or whatever else so
um yeah so that's kind of the methodology for what i'm going to look at and you know obviously always
pivoting to new invites and just like basically conventional wisdom in that regard um and by new
invites i mean not new to me but completely new programs um as far as far as time as far as time
spent and i think this may have been what you were double clicking on because uh obviously we just
launched shift but um that so that'll probably be 60 to 70 of my time as full-time bug bounty and the
other bits will be obviously recording and supporting critical thinking but then outside of that i would
love to build more tools and so shift is the first one and so i'll be doing you know some maintenance
and updates and features on that but um i would i would love to build other kind of ai apps specifically
in the security space so in fact if people do have ideas i think that um the current ai models kind of
unlock an entire new class and suite of tools that are possible some of those require a lot more work
some of them don't require very much at all you just kind of throw it together and the ability to
develop so fast now with things like cursor as i know you've mentioned many times it makes it so
possible so yeah yeah lots of building too the um the the shift thing like i i've been amazed at how
active you've been in that man i could say i like you know we launched this thing and then guys like
every person that subscribes i see rezo like just sending out an email being like hey how do you like
the product what do you think you know give me ideas customer attention come on dude you're you're
rocking it man and really you know for anybody who's who's um subscribing to it right now and
getting access to it uh we're really interested in and you know your use cases that aren't being
fulfilled or um you know anything any future progression we definitely want to hear about that
and actually i was kind of thinking about this i had it in the notes to talk about on this episode
um you know i've been working on this program recently where we have api specs um and they're just
sort of uh free form in like a like a csv or whatever and i was like oh man how cool would it
be to like in in sort of like a cursor like fashion just saying like hey here's this document that
contains api specs here's what i want you to do with this with this row do you know this column do this
you know set this to the host you know generate this token you know put it here you know that sort of
thing and then just have shift sort of automatedly parse out this api spec and then create it into a
collection in kaido where you know each one of the requests is built out fully and and i think you know
we can sort of do that lower scale right now with with shift you could paste in like one or two lines
of the that's back and it will actually create them and stick them in in replay but i think being able
to upload a full document and then break it out into certain sections and then like create the
requests for those as as it goes along as it parses through the whole document would be another really
cool feature we could integrate yeah yeah that's a cool idea i think that um it's probably already
possible with uh with a few changes uh so i like it as an idea and i like that it basically would give
you then a list of um tabs to go through and replay where it's like i'll test this one then i'll test this
one then i'll test this one and it's every endpoint yeah yeah the crazy thing one of the craziest
things about ai that i really just haven't like put into words before is how much it enables you to
deal with freeform stuff you know like you never know what format you're going to get documentation
in it could be a big word doc could be in csv could be in like swagger files could be in this but if you
can just tell the ai hey this is what it looks like this is where the information you need is you know
then you can really easily get that from a format from any format from a you know freeform format
into a format that you can ingest and then put into a tool um and that that sort of thing is just
not possible without ai without it smartly identifying yeah i don't currently have automation that like
takes bug bounty scope and then like transforms it into something that my automation uses or needs
but that's a great that's a great place where that would exist like as i'm sure you know anybody
who tries to do that programmatically realizes that the the scope fields across the different
platforms are different and wild cards will sometimes look different or sometimes they'll put it in the
description or whatever but what's interesting is i could definitely abstract that out if you had
it like set up with a specific schema that you wanted so geez man this is another reason i'm
really excited to have you on the pod is it's really great to have a local ai expert um and sort
of be able to talk about um how to take these these applications of ai stuff and apply it to security
and i know that that's like your so yeah yeah so i mean i guess i can i can pre-apologize and pre-prep the
listener that uh i'm sure i'll bring lots of ai content just even prepping for this episode as me
and jester and i were coming up with resources i had to kind of like control myself because i just
wanted to keep putting in more ai stuff in there so uh yeah i think it'll help usher the listeners
into a world where they're using ai and integrating into their lives earlier than their peers which is
going to give them a huge level up but i also think that they'll understand the way ai applications
are being built and that's going to give them a huge leg up and actually hacking these applications later
yeah dude massive massive value out there and i think i'll always you know bring a bunch of web
stuff as i do you know so i i think it's great to have a counterbalance there of like all right here's
some ai here's some tooling um and then also the web stuff i mean you've got web stuff in your list
right here too so um yeah i'm dude i'm excited man this is gonna be awesome thank you so much for
joining the team no no no thank you so much thanks thanks for selecting me slash uh bringing me on as the
co-host it's a real pleasure and honor and i do not take it for granted so thank you awesome all
right well um trying to think if i had anything else that i wanted to run by you before we just
kind of jump into the content for this episode um yeah i think that's a good i think that's a good
intro man if the if the listeners don't know who you are at this point you know you guys can find
him on on on twitter if you want to read more he's uh he's pretty big on twitter you're like what
what 50 something thousand followers so yeah i think almost 55 but um honestly i've been hearing
from people who are in the social media realm that it's like almost uh that it can be a hindrance
because like if you have like a split audience that the low engagement rate ratio to your followers
can be whatever but it doesn't matter yeah i definitely post a ton of stuff by ai bug bounty so
i'm on twitter at rezo underscore underscore um which by the way if we have any listeners from twitter
there's no one using rez zero the account so hook a boy up sometime i want it and it's unused and you
can't register four character uh usernames anymore so no oh really oh you can't yeah so i can't go
steal it but and then i also blog a lot so uh you all can check out josephbacker.com yeah yeah the um
the uh newsletter is great too so i i love your writing style in the newsletter um so cool stuff there
all right well let's let's go into the the content for this week um we already talked a little bit about
shift in like how i think that can be really uh useful for um grabbing freeform api docs and kind
of getting them integrated into your request and your replay um in kaido um but there was a cool
piece of research that comes out and or that came out and i just every single time um paulos
yabelo uh releases something it's it's very um it's very like outside of the box you know thinking
and weaponizing some things that a lot of people take for graded um and and so i i follow i follow
their research pretty closely um and this time uh they released an article called double click jacking
a new era of ui redressing and i've also seen some research uh it might come out through the the
critical research lab soon um that just also really really weaponize as well um pages that can be framed
so like previously i wouldn't really consider uh x frame options header missing as like a like a like
a mega gadget yeah but um after seeing this and after seeing some of the research from the lab
um there is a lot of stuff you could do um if you have extra no extreme options header and same site uh
uh cookies are not an issue um and the way that this specific research sort of addresses this scenario is
it invites a user to double click on something and with the first click the mouse down event it it um
it harvests that to close a window and then you know the mouse up event happens and when the mouse down
event happens again the user's uh cursor right where it was on that button will be aligned over a sort of
popped under page that was done in preparation for this attack and can harvest a single click on a button
on a a sensitive page and um i was like okay you know that's kind of kind of crafty kind of cool you
know and then i i went and looked at these um these uh demo videos that he recorded for salesforce slack
shopify and one click account takeovers and they're pretty freaking good dude double click account take
overs yeah double click exactly i mean on the on the on the platform that's one but then the vulnerability is
also one yeah so right right but it you mean technically yeah i guess it's a it's a two click
you know because you're going to do but um you know you go on there you you click the captcha especially
excuse me especially with captchas and uh accept cookies stuff priming users to just give a click
without a second thought um i think this will result in some very impactful stuff if done correctly
um i'm not i'm not sure i would report this as is but uh maybe change with something else like the oauth
low um i think it's i think it's worthwhile i think it's a valid bug yeah so uh before we jump to
kind of the really cool kind of mitigations here uh which are really neat so you all definitely want
to listen to that i just wanted to say click jacking in general i definitely have always kind of like
you know like you said look down my nose at from a bug bounty hunting perspective but yeah i don't know
but i think that yeah i think i'm underrating it a little bit i remember jesse uh hogarth 45 back
yeah like three years ago showed me an amazing click jacking uh vulnerability that resulted in like
a account takeover and then recently in the google event in malaga spain this fall or i guess back in
november somebody had a really neat click jacking demo that it was like based around gmail so i don't
know i don't know i don't know all the details and i don't know if i could share them anyways because i
think we were under nda but um but there was a vulnerability that paid out that was like extremely impactful
that uh did some click jacking and some like uh kind of user trickery where like it had the user
play a little game for the captcha that resulted in extremely like a severe impact so it's worth uh
it's worth considering this this blog is just it's well written and the poc is like you said are our
money do you want to talk about these really cool mitigation things he brought up yeah yeah so um
definitely the mitigation things are we'll get to those in just a second but i just want to echo that
like the the crazy thing about click jacking is i think it gets a bad rap because
like people will report it without proving impact right but just think about this for a second you
know in a lot of scenarios that they're talking about there where you're approving you know all
that application with one click that can you know do anything to your account that's the highest amount
of impact you can achieve on the client side right if you if you have a you know one click account
takeover that is the highest amount of impact you can achieve on the client side period right so if you
if you are in in a click jacking scenario where you come to the attacker's page you click one button on
that page right that is like one and your account gets pwned that is like one click away from the
highest impact uh scenario that you can run into on the client side so i mean it's really this is one of
the classes where it's really about weaponization and if you can take it and take it the full the full
mile and uh and and get the account takeover out of it or gets you know maybe if you can one click delete
your account or you know one click do some other um very sensitive action uh then i think that will
often result in in some uh accepted bug yeah and isn't reflected xss basically the same thing like
it's still a one click kind of account take over the thing with rxss is you can like spray it because you
can kind of put that payload anywhere whereas i think a lot of click jacking you have to get them on your page
but in general it's kind of the same right you just spray the link to your safe looking page that is
malicious that has the the framed page on it and so it still looks legitimate and so yeah i think
they're very similar like you said click jacking as like an as like a phrase may be kind of um
frowned upon but in general if you still have a weaponized payload it should probably it should
probably be taken seriously so yeah for sure okay what is this uh what are these protections for the
double click jacking stuff that they had here yeah i think i was pointing this out to you when we were
talking about it before the before the pod it's just like it's so neat that um there's both a
javascript based protection here mitigation that anyone can implement on these on these super
sensitive pages where a single click has like a lot of impact and then and then um they also go
into the details for how browsers could completely fix this which i think which i think you thought
was neat uh yeah that actually would would be implemented yeah no this is this is great uh i think
there should be some addressing of this at the at the browser level but i mean especially for those
programs that want to be very thorough with their like with the places in their application where one
click can take over your account right because that's a pretty stringent scenario already and
pretty much the only only place you kind of see this is is an oauth authorization um uh and and so if
you just add this one little snippet of javascript which um you know removes the the risk of double
click jacking by deceiving critical buttons uh unless a gesture is detected um then you you know you you
save yourself from this sort of attack even if you have to allow the page to be um uh framed uh which
which and actually in this scenario it's it's not even uh framing because they're they're popping it
up in a lot of a lot of ways so um there's there's a bunch of um scenarios where this can be exploited
exploited further but just being able to add that one little snippet into your page to make sure that
there's some movement of the mouse that sort of thing before that button becomes enabled i think is
something that should be added to those high high value oauth pages where it can result in in one
click ato because you those pages need special security concern anyway so this is just one extra
step yeah it does it reminds me of the vulnerabilities you found with css and injection and on those credit
card pages it's like when there's a highly sensitive page things that might not typically be vulnerabilities
can kind of become those and honestly another really key point about this blog is that like he gives
you the mitigation and i think i think having mitigation in bug bounty reports is one of the
best ways to get them accepted and to also get those kind of like well-written report bonuses and
stuff and it makes it makes teams take you seriously it's like hey here's a vulnerability and here's how
you fix it right now you just put this javascript on the page and it removes this and i think it really
showcases the fact that there is a vulnerability and that there is a single fix in that single place
yeah yeah for sure and and dude i i gotta you gotta remind me as we record future episodes um the our
editor has said that i really should be sharing my screen when i'm talking about these articles so we
can get it up on youtube sorry sorry folks i'll try to remind you i i always forget to do that but i
just want did want to add one more thing as we as we move away from the subject which is that um just
want to quote specifically from the article here it says um double click jacking adds a layer many defenses
were never designed to handle methods like x frame options same site cookies and csp cannot defend
against this attack so i know we sort of covered click jacking as a as a specific um attack you know
while we were talking about double click jacking but double click jacking is very different because
it uses uh like pop-up windows and stuff like that um and so you know it's going to be a top level
navigation so same time it passes all of your cookies it's a it's a completely legitimate click on the
under on the under page yeah there's no protection for that part yeah there's there's nothing you can
do with that um and it doesn't have anything to do with framing either so it's not going to happen
and and um you know a lot of these uh modern day attacks that utilize uh different windows and frames
um will uh be stopped by coop um which is um cross origin uh i forget the actual let me let me look
up the actual acronym um uh cross origin opener policy yeah that's it um which you know removes
that opener relationship um but this one i think could also be implemented without even though coop was
in place so there's lots of uh ways that this attack sort of bypasses traditional attack mechanisms
um uh so just wanted to make sure that was clear and we weren't getting confused with click jacking and
and uh the prerequisites for that attack um all right so we're worth testing worth testing in places
where those protections still exist because they are still vulnerable most of the time i think you kind
of have to feel out the teams as well because some teams are going to be like yeah well you know
what are we gonna do you know but um if you're working with teams that are high quality and the poc is
really clean then it could get accepted or it could not get accepted you know and that's just kind of the
risk you take with these sort of fringe attacks that require a little bit more user interaction
yeah they say in here that the that the uh results were mixed but this but he says most have chosen
to address it while some have chosen not to so honestly i i would have expected the opposite but i
would not surprise me if the mitigation being a part of the report is one reason why they were like
yeah we'll just accept this and throw this mitigation on the page right so yeah that's great
um okay cool so that was the double click jacking one um you want to hop down to expo stuff
yeah so um i actually am an advisor at ethiac uh which is the um one of the kind of automated hacking
platforms out of portugal started by our boy andre oxacb shout out to our borough xacb yeah he's the man
and so as a part of that you know um they may or may not be working on a hackbot but uh in my research
for that and in my support of that um i yeah shared with them this validation benchmark it's actually two
top bug hunters dorado and do you know the other person is yeah neiman sec right yeah yeah neiman
sec are both on the expo team and so expo is building a hackbot stack it is yeah it's it's um yeah
it's amazing and the founders are also like really brilliant but um so anyways this link will be in the
show notes but if you if you want to search for it yourself if you just look up expo engineering
validation benchmarks they have man over 100 benchmarks which are really cool they include
like uh like a docker compose file that will help you spin up a little app that has a single
vulnerability that you can then um test your ai system at hacking so like let's say that you're
a bug hunter and you want to start implementing ai to be able to solve your xss or your idor or
whatever just just to play with it either to learn it or because legit it could pay off and make you money
this is like a perfect place to go to test those um systems against little micro exploits where
they're very vulnerable these are not like hard things to solve for the majority of them and i
think they increase in difficulty but wow yeah so this these this is sort of a this benchmarking is a lot
of work you know putting together all of these github repos and and oh yeah or docker containers and
stuff like that and uh they've kind of done that legwork and then released it for the community so that
they can um so that people can use these to make sure their hack bots are are achieving the goal
um and and i think that's really cool because a lot of times when i'm building automation i need
a a test case you know a vulnerable test case right yes and uh oftentimes i train them off the actual
vulnerabilities that i find manually um but if you don't have those on hand or if you'd like to you
know train it on what you found manually and then sort of apply it to a benchmark and say hey does it but
does it figure out this scenario um this is a great way to to validate that um and and i guess
they have it um broken out into like what specific types of bugs are each one of yeah they don't they
don't at the top level but if you click into them they definitely do so yeah um actually i don't know
that the titles even when you click in are not oh yeah so vulnerability type and category yeah it's in
the readme yeah so so like idor um oh and also difficulty too i hadn't noticed that there's a difficulty
field so you could even like you know cherry pick the easy ones or cherry pick the hard ones or
whatever nice yeah cross-site scripting injection difficulty hard interesting cool yeah so these
will definitely be helpful for anybody who's building a hackbot um which i think there are more and more
researchers uh yeah in the full-time hunters guild i won't leave their name but one of the full-time
hunters has already uh found a high vulnerability with their own personal hackbot that they train
themselves to write in like a week so yeah we're sort of talented developers so yeah we got it we got
to definitely make sure we're staying on top of uh of all that i think it's going to be helpful to
have one of those on your team uh as you keep moving forward um okay any any other comments on
that one or is that that one do that no i was going to ask you about this jorian tweet yeah okay get some
water my third is a little scratchy today um yeah so uh obviously you know let me just say what i say all
the time when gareth hayes tweets anything you should pay attention to that tweet um and gareth tweeted out on
christmas eve uh and we're just getting the chance to cover it now that uh he found that you can use
iso uh 2022 jp on char set escape sequences inside of js urls so uh this is going to break a lot of uh
uh wafts and hard-coded uh like scenarios where they're just just looking for javascript colon right
if they had like a hard-coded no javascript colon um you know taking in in some accommodations for
html encoding and stuff like that um then that's very hard to bypass when you're trying to to do a
a um a url or like an href based attack um but this this scenario that he outlines here allows you to
to do a payload and i will share my screen on this one now so people can people can actually see the tweet
um yeah in this in this scenario he outlines uh a way to actually get it to pop with a bunch of whack
characters in there um so this and then there was another comment so this is where jorian comes in
a little bit further down on twitter um where he says hey uh gareth was saying hey this doesn't work
on chrome and jorian noticed that if you just spam the uh the escape sequence for this uh specific
character set a bunch of times then chrome successfully sniffs it if there's no character
set defined on that page and will actually trigger it even though it doesn't work right off the bat
like it does in firefox so um this works in both firefox and chrome if there's no character set defined
that you can send in this payload like javas space you know uh escape sequence thing um script
colon alert one um and it will actually trigger that in the browser um and they provided some
example links on how this might work in that twitter thread so we'll have those linked in the
description but um yeah did you see my reply amazing no did you reply yeah yeah so in in in
our doc here click click on my link there's no spam and it still pops so i don't know if um if it's just
my browser locally that's behaving that way or if jorian was um incorrect and just figured out a
different way to make it pop but basically i was like that spam doesn't feel that necessary so i went and
started removing some of those characters and it it totally pops for me in chrome if you remove a
bunch of them so maybe maybe more research required there yeah so i think you still have one of the
one or two of the escape sequences so maybe you don't need to do that many but there's like a smaller
amount of escape sequences that you can use and create a more consolidated payload nice i like that
yeah we'll um we'll drop that down in the description as well richard um the one that's highlighted in the
doc uh if you could add that to the description that would be great um okay cool so yeah i just
want i i kind of want to keep the community up to date on those these sort of uh character set
related attacks that have been kind of popping up a ton lately perfect for waft bypasses and other
things yeah yeah it's it's great for those scenarios and i think it's a little bit less common that the
character set isn't defined but just like scenarios that we were just talking about where you know um
extreme options headers might be missing uh this is stuff that we weren't really paying attention to
as much before but like now i think should start really being like ah this is a gadget you know if
there's no character set to find this is a gadget if there's some ability to inject any text in the
page um which is a pretty low bar to me right in my opinion so yeah did i don't i know i'm sure that
you probably already geeked out about this but what's funny about this character set specifically is
it's for like a japanese email it's like a 2022 japanese code point email thing and yeah yeah it's
hilarious yeah dude i love i love it when my my interests overlap like that um uh when you've got
some stuff that's only available in japanese i love it when um uh kinagawa masato uh released some stuff
in japanese first and i get to go like read it and be like he he he he like i understand this
um and then he does the english release like a day later and i'm like she's but but um i do love it
when there's there's that aspect um so speaking of gareth hayes yeah yeah dude so you you dropped this
one this svg related tweet in here as well right yeah yeah so um obviously svg xss has been around a
little while um and i do uh know and remember your rule about always paying attention to gareth's tweets so
i actually wanted to i wanted to ask you why specifically and justin would not answer this
offline everyone because we thought it'd be great contact for the podcast what is special about this
uh payload that made him you know tweet and share it yeah so um the the payload that gareth shared is a
svg xss payload um and like you said you know it's pretty common knowledge that we can get xss from svgs
uh if the content type is uh image slash xvg plus xml um and then it's being loaded up in in a frame
in the browser right it doesn't work from an image tag um which is a common misconception um but what
gareth tweeted out here that's a little bit special is that uh you can actually use ht or um xml entities
to sort of prime this attack uh which may help bypass some uh wafts that are blocking your your
malicious uh svg payload or it can also help in the scenario where the your svg is being sanitized um
when it's being uploaded because there are some svg softwares that will look and say okay you know
is there an a href item in here that um is being dynamically generated or is there a script tag that's
being you know that's being created when i'm create uh uploading this svg file and then stripping it
out so it's non-malicious um gareth is highlighting here that you can actually use uh xml entities which
is something we normally just associate with server-side attacks um for xxc to actually craft a malicious
svg um that actually only becomes malicious at runtime when that the xml is parsed by the browser
um yeah that's interesting like you said that even if you stripped out any script tags this would still
make it through that wife or make it through that sanitization so yeah 100 so this is another one
that's that's kind of interesting to keep in your in your pocket um and i just want to shoot out a
reminder because there's a there's a couple you know higher level hackers recently that i was talking to
that seemed to be under the the concept uh that you could get sv uh xss from an svg um that was
loaded into an image tag and you know i'm happy to be proven wrong but i've never seen that work
uh it's just when the browser is parsing or parsing the svg and in the frame directly so you navigate
directly to that svg um uh that that that payload will actually pop and that's because the browser is
parsing xml as as well with that with that svg i'm not just considering it to be an image right
so yeah that's a cool shout out as well there from gareth um dude my throat is dying man it's you know
it's winter here it's been snowing this whole week and my everything is just so dry it's you got snow as
well right yeah we got i mean i'm sure that this is true all across the us especially across the midwest
we're getting more snow than we've basically ever gotten um we got like eight inches here in kentucky
and you know like three yeah and three to six are coming in the next two days um so i'm enjoying the
cold plunge my wife got me for christmas oh my gosh that's got to be legendary yeah we got like four
inches here in in virginia um but we've had we've had worse before so yeah the kids are having fun with
hit though for sure nice um well i mean your throat will make it through the next two i think right we've
only got two left yeah yeah so let me let me jump back over i'm gonna just do one quick shout out um
to a project called curl dash cffi um this so many of you as you're building automation um will run a
scenario where uh these these sites are running cloudflare and they will not like your tls um handshake
that you do from like python requests or something like that um someone created this awesome project in in
python called curl dash cffi which essentially allows you to impersonate uh chrome's tls uh
signature or uh fingerprint and use it in python and you can just literally import from it like
import from uh curl cffi as requests and then it just use it like you normally would in request so you
need to you're obsessed with these matrices make sure you share your screen and show the matrix of the
support on there okay all right hold on let me let me do it because j json himself is a big fan of
these uh of these uh matrices i love and and then on top of that this this uh tool is really cool so
yeah this is great so this is the this is the tool right here curl cffi um and it's super easy to
integrate um into the project you can literally i'll i'm showing it on the screen now but um you can just
from curl underscore cffi import requests and then use requests just exactly like you would uh as as
your primary you know http interface in python so and it allows you to impersonate chrome um super super
simply which has allowed me to get around a bunch of uh cloudflare related stuff um so i wanted to just
shout that out there for anybody who might be dealing with similar issues there um and then i'll
jump right into this cs cspt um yeah thing if that's cool with you before my voice kicks out
so we're recording this on the 9th and this was released this morning so uh sorry guys if i
haven't uh if i don't do it full justice uh to the homies over there at uh doyan sec but um they've
been doing some really awesome work on one of my favorite bug types uh client-side path traversal and
we've done a bunch of um master classes and stuff like this uh on this on this actual vulnerability
type in the the discord so check those out if you're interested um but the research that came out
was essentially how to use a uh one of the ways to exploit cspt because cspt by itself is not a
vulnerability it's a gadget and that gadget has to be weaponized with another gadget um and one of the
most common ways to do that there's like open redirect um there's like response poisoning or whatever
um and then one of the most common ones is to get a file uploaded onto the server that has like a
json in it and then get the cspt to traverse hit that json file the the javascript that triggered that
that fetch request or whatever will parse that json and use your malicious values um and integrate them
into the dom and cause xss or some bad um uh you know effect on the application um so what the people
over at doyansec did was a little bit of research on how to get fetch to process json uh effectively and
with different file types and the one the one that they released here was uh pdf um and how a lot of
the libraries for uploading pdfs will use very liberal checking of the magic bytes at the beginning of the
file and uh what was it like in the first yeah in the first like 1200 uh 1024 characters if there is
percent pdf then it will bypass the pdf upload um the pdf uploader will still think this is a pdf and
you can actually integrate just normal json um into that that file which can then be processed by uh by the
um csbt so uh they they provided a couple different um libraries pdf lib um and what was the other one
uh file file type within a specific um live uh language i can't find the other one here but there's
a couple um libraries that were vulnerable to this in a magic and then pdf pdf lib and then that one you
just mentioned yeah the crazy thing is like to me this is really cool because i'm always thinking about
you know the highest impact possible and i love that file uploads are so frequently uh considered rce
you know this um in this case it may or may not be i didn't have a chance like you said you sent
me this this morning i didn't get to read it all but yeah i just threw it in front of you
that's fine in general file uploads are often rce right and so like understanding the way that the
back-end server is deciding whether or not a file type is allowed was really cool to me like when
i was reading that i was like oh wow this is amazing like not only can i potentially trick the
content type you know header or directive there but then you can also you know like i've known about
magic bytes and how to potentially modify those but it's it's it's a really um cool idea that and i
guess it's more just a cool vulnerability yeah that some of these libraries do something as simple as
look for the magic byte of you know percent pdf or whatever within the first thousand bytes so well
that's a great point i mean this is this research is cross applicable in lots of areas right
right yes very permissive um parsing of this file type then you might end up being able to get
files on the server that uh are more or that contain malicious content easier um so and normally when i
think about the magic bytes right i'm thinking oh these have to be um defined at the very beginning of
the first bite yeah um but apparently there are a lot of uh pdf parsing engines that will allow it to be
anywhere in the first 1024 bytes so yeah this this gives us a lot of flexibility not only with client
side path reversals but uh which you know would just normally result in xss or some impact on the
client side but also um when uh file upload scenarios like you mentioned yeah yeah pretty solid uh definitely
big shout out to the to their team they've been really diving deep on the specific vulnerability type
um and i i love to see the research come out and check that out dude they shouted they give you a
mention nice they did they did and oh yeah that was the other thing i'm glad i scrolled down to the
bottom to flex on the people about my shout out in this blog um because they also uh mention this um
csbt playground which is a github repo that they um released that contains a docker container and a
bunch of little um labs that you can do to strengthen your cspt knowledge uh and guys let me tell you
this gadget is everywhere cspt is everywhere um massive bug type that is uh underrated by uh the
security community in general i think uh so definitely something you want to kind of wrap your head around
and be able to exploit uh if you're doing web application auditing with any frequency yep there you go
all right what what's the uh what's the last one you got on your list here ai crash course
yeah so i mean um in general everyone wants a quick easy hack right and everyone loves those uh
resource-based githubs where it's like here's a list of all the resources you need to know about xss
and i do think it's kind of easy to ignore them or not ever go through them um but if people are willing
to buckle down and really learn i think that you can learn a lot of stuff in under two weeks and that's
what this um that's what this link uh is they got shared let me see if i can share it really quickly
share screen oh sweet yeah single chrome tab perfect so uh this has been going around in a bunch of the
ai engineering circles um along with a subtext that's basically like get you know become an ai
engineer in two weeks so supposedly you could you could take this ai crash course in in two weeks but
it's just a list of resources if you had to go from zero understanding to full comprehension of how
current ai engineering works basically it starts with like how do neural networks like what exactly
is an neural network so you can kind of skip some of the stuff if you want poke around and then they
even highlight with asterisk the most important ones to uh focus on um but yeah there's a list of
paper yeah there's a list of papers a list of the major applications some of the benchmarks and then the
video lecture series you know this is probably if i were spinning up where i would spend my time i i
don't know why i just learned really well by watching and then doing and so i would probably follow these
a while building stuff on the side as i go specifically andre andre kaparthi's series is great and i in
general i don't think that especially the hacker community needs to like be training their own models
or doing anything crazy like that but understanding the power of these models and understanding how to plug them
um up with like tools and and hook them up to different capabilities and functionality is really
going to give you a leg up when it comes to hacking or building your own uh your your own like ai tooling
or your own you know ai infrastructure for yourself yeah so i just wanted to share this with the community
because i thought it was a really great resource you know pick and choose click through learn kind of
fill in some of your gaps if you're interested in it yeah and i think even just understanding the basics
of like link chain and um and getting all this stuff in your your normal development environment
in python or in node or whatever your go or whatever you're writing in um is really really really helpful
because then you can start using these this tool you know ai just as another piece of your automation
um uh and yeah i think any any any time you you move forward and you utilize ai you're kind of
providing more cushion for yourself if you're worried at all about ai really affecting the security industry
because you are now weaponizing that thing you're going to be the one that pushes that that industry
a little bit further with your innovation using the ai so definitely yeah i don't think wild topic
yeah and i don't think we're all going to be replaced or anything anytime soon but let's say in
five or ten years we were to like see actual impact on bug bounty from these this type of automation
because expo pops off or something you know i think in general kind of getting up to speed with ai is
going to mean that you will be the cream of the crop when it comes to companies that are trying to
utilize or build on top of ai or you know want to implement or learn like what products are out there
so in general i think it's a really nice hedge because it's going to level yourself up while um
while increasing your productivity so yeah i mean expo was what 11th in the us that that last year that
was crazy um so definitely definitely something to keep an eye out if you know i'm not going to call out you
know our homies uh you know that work at expo at all um i don't know how much of that is like expo's
product finding bugs and like fully exploiting them on bug bounty program um i literally honestly just
don't know but i know that it would not be very hard for the folks that work at at at expo to get in
the 11th place in the us like those guys are some of the most talented hunters out there the the team
from spain over there um so definitely um excited to see that though because i think there is a lot
of progress being made in the industry there yeah yeah sweet i guess one other thing i was going to
ask you about as before we close here was um if there was anything on your top of mind for the
listeners as they we go into 2025 since we just had the kind of all hands meeting with the cdb ctbb team
was there anything from that that kind of flowed over that you thought the listener needed to know
yeah i mean i i think i think just as far as the direction that ctbb is going in 2025 um you know
we're really going to try to focus on the research lab uh you know trying to get research from the
research lab and present it on the pod so it's going to be original research and i just sort of
reiterated with the whole team the north star for critical thinking which is we want to um deliver
you know high energy motivational very technically informative content every week to the community
um with the goal of you know even the most skilled researchers coming away from each episode with
like oh yeah i hadn't really thought of that or uh you know i have one actionable takeaway that that
will change their methodology as they approach a target um and that's kind of what the north star has
been and i think will continue to be um throughout throughout 2025 it is easy to lose track of that
but um i we do have the team keeping us accountable now you know focusing in on that and and really um trying
to spend more time developing the the plans for these episodes so that we can get that technical depth
required to achieve that goal yep absolutely i mean i think that that's been why i've loved critical
thinking so much and i think that it is a perfect north star right um because our audience base all
of the listeners all of our friends that we talk to and hang out with all the time are such practical
people like we all just want the practical brass tacks advice let me go implement this so i can
you know succeed more make more money um or or just do something really groundbreaking and i think
you know we care a lot about those really cool novel breakthroughs um the hacker hacker culture and
hacker subculture has always been really um has always gotten really excited about novel breakthroughs
new techniques new strategies yeah and yeah we want to bring that to you all dude it's it's crazy
though to see to be in the this researcher chat with the critic with the critical thinking research
team like like you know we've got franz we've got we've got matan in there we've got mizu we've got
monkey hacks we've got uh hakupiku pikuhaku wherever in discord versus twitter but i mean that that team
is really stacked and they really already just in the like week we've launched this have bounced off of
each other a lot being like oh what if we did this so we could weaponize this this way um so i really
expect to see some awesome stuff out of them in 2025 that i'm really going to be privileged to
distribute that on the podcast i think yeah and one thing i think i told you in the all hands a
minute ago and i told the rest of the team i think that everything we talk about here is extremely
applicable to people out there who are web app testing or pen testing and i want the leaders of
those org i want the leaders of those organizations to like be thinking like oh our employees our hackers
have to be listening to ctbb because that's going to make them the best version of themselves that's going
to make them the best hackers on the planet and so yeah if you listen or if you work at a place where
you've got you know friends who are doing pen testing or are doing web app testing like
definitely refer the pod recommend people to check it out yeah yeah definitely all right man i think
that's a wrap on this episode i'm gonna go get some like snow and like put it on my throat it's so raspy
sweet dude yeah thanks again um i'm excited about this year can't wait to to bring more awesome content to
you all sweet peace and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for listening and if you
want more critical thinking content head over to ctbb.show discord join the discord there's lots of
great conversations and chats going on over there and if you want to support the show there's the
discord subscriber tiers which give you access to master classes amas hack alongs exclusive scripts
and an exclusive chat channel with us we'll see you there